what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here was on yes it is morning I have
pulled an all-nighter once again for the
Marvel Studios Avengers infinity war
official trailer got to get this show on
the road people let's get to it what are
we waiting for why isn't the trailer
loading oh my goodness come on hurry up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she's coming to us Wow we have a dentist
once so that's what we use
nice Jerry let's talk about this plan
tears I think it's good except it sucks
so let me do the plan that way it might
be really good
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh got a flashbac that's it oh it's a
shot heard about
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
Oh
I'm Peter by the way dr. strange Oh
using your made-up names then I am
spider
mmm get tickets now we gotta buy tickets
right away okay well let's uh let's
fight it's ten minutes ago let's watch
this again oh we go watches one more
time 1 million sound effects really
[Music]
he's coming to us I love it ever try to
use the Infinity stones against him
we're beta in some way that's going to
work see them so excited it sucks so let
me do the plan and that way it might be
really good
[Music]
I like to encounter a remix version of
like the redone version of this song
yeah
like ominous war
[Music]
that's a flashback right after war which
is a child
that's sháá dude oh man
[Music]
[Music]
I hope they run
[Music]
let's recap dies everyone knows that
that's what cap died I'm Peter Bailey
sausage trench Oh
[Music]
I'm really loving the way they're doing
the marketing for this because they're
still not revealing a lot I actually
when I was up all night I was reading
this giant long ass interview with the
Russo brothers in Collider where they
were talking about balancing a whole
bunch of different tones and styles
because by variety of characters and
just from this trailer beginning teases
I love how they're not giving away a lot
of details right here it had a good mix
of the right character interaction and
humor mixed with the emotional chaotic
situations and I really feel like the
Russo brothers are really gonna pull
this off well yeah I mean I feel like
the first trailer really emphasized the
arrival of Thanos in every band this one
is all about the convergence of like you
said your different worlds and just the
hits feel really hard in this trailer it
feels like an all-out war cuz this movie
has to do like what the Avengers did
times 12 well yeah that many more
characters with their own rules in their
own worlds and stuff that's why that
seemed you know with star-lord and Tony
Stark it was like a deconstructed
version of oh yeah what I said in the
first movie is you're I feel like you're
gonna get some hilarious banter you're
like I love all I love this scenes were
like meeting each other you know it's
spider-man and Doctor Strange talking to
each other that's a great closing bit
right there and they finally showed us
that piece of footage that I heard that
was at the d23 Expo in the comic-con one
where Thanos is like crushing Thor's
head that's so intense yeah well that's
the thing about this trailer - is it
looks like it's gonna be a struggle
for the Avengers this is gonna be hard
and not just that us in here I mean you
got that one shot in this trailer where
it looked like that was from the Black
Order Corvis it was like doing the
spikey thinks the doctor Strange's face
so the trailers haven't really been
showing you a lot of like the black orga
characters but we know they're in here I
think that right there is a great tease
as to what they could possibly be doing
with them because right now it's been
like Santos Avengers but the black wars
been hinted at is there gonna be a
serious part of the threat as well yeah
well they gotta be you know he's got to
have his his core team yeah take them
down and in fact that's that's the only
thing
it concerns me as that whole thing at
the beginning about like he's only got
one goal and that's to wipe out half the
universe I'm like that's your motivation
well he's kind of like wanting to
cleanse though that's that's a big but
more than they don't got a reason gene
that's a specific Thanos thing in the
comic book I know yeah I mean in the
shot right here they showed us that Iron
Man's getting a new suit inside of like
the Entertainment Weekly spot and you
could definitely tell like what his feet
changed because they said that his suit
will allow him to kind of go into space
and this is going really high in the sky
we've seen that in other Iron Man movies
he can only get to a certain level and
in here he's going way up in this guy
that looks like he's possibly rule
ascending into space potentially
somewhere around it yeah and it looks
like that fight at Wakanda might be the
big finale fight in my opinion because
that's what they were taking down the
Hulkbuster man that can only mean
something serious yeah cuz this is being
divided into two parts and I feel like a
lot of people are gonna Rob you
theorizing that this is when Captain
America might die I don't think it is
I'm gonna to show that in the trailer
I'm sure people have fun thinking about
that maybe it'll be the moment where he
we think he's dead but you know excited
for the second one and of course you
know they showed this flashback with
Thanos and Gamora cuz we've always heard
a lot about Gamora being you know raised
by Thanos and like the kind of evil
upbringing she had where she had to
fight against nebula and stuff so maybe
we might get even hints at that we might
see a little nebula and little Gamora
fighting each other yeah I mean at very
least when they all crash into each
other and she's got explain who orders
everybody yeah sure they'll be room for
for a little bit of expounding on their
lives and growing up oh man that was a
great great Drake trailer man I really
yeah I can't wait to get our tickets
right now I'm max baby you got to do it
right now
driver the real rejects click that
notification melih get notified every
time one of our vids is up and check us
out on patreon full-length TV show
reactions over there as well as weekly
Q&A as we do full-length video responses
to every question a patron asks you can
leave recommendations of whatnot would
love to have you over there see you guys